tributes to sir david amos have come in
from across the political divide with
many pointing to his commitment to the
local area and his constituents i want
to speak now to two members of
parliament from the essex region the
conservative mp for romford andrew
rossendell who's been friends with sir
david for 40 years and the labour mp for
ilford north west streeting
thank you gentlemen for joining us it's
unusual for us to have two members of
parliament on together especially from
different
parties but i'd like you both to reflect
on your
experience not as partisans but as
constituency mps
who
were close to sir david
and i just would like starting with you
andrew
if you want to say something about your
memories of him
david was a wonderful person he was a
really genuine friend
we've all got friends in parliament he
was special because he really cared
about
the people around him he cared about his
constituency
he was a passionate person and he had
strong beliefs he he was uncompromising
what he stood for
but the things he stood for
were wonderful causes for instance
animal welfare he was
he was a huge animal welfare supporter
and
the other thing i'd say about him is
that
he would
always have time for everybody he met
you know he didn't just brush you off he
he would spend time talking to all all
the people he met and nothing would be
too much he never looked down on anyone
he was he he was an equal to everyone
else that's the way he he behaved and
we're going to miss him he was a
fantastic mp and a great friend and
for him to lose him in this such tragic
circumstances um
it's very difficult for us to accept and
understand it really is it's a very sad
moment for all of us
where's streeting
yeah i think we were just discussing
before we came on um david was one of
those great characters in parliament
everyone knew him because you could not
know him um he was
renowned for as andrew said the cause he
took up
a terrific sense of humor and also just
the most outstanding champion for his
constituency and i've not checked but i
would put money on the fact that no one
has ever mentioned south end in
parliament more than sir david did and
i'm really glad actually that the
campaign for city status for south end
is um you know really up at the top of
the agenda because i could think of no
more fitting tribute to him and he was
loved right across the political
spectrum and you've heard that in recent
days from some of my labor colleagues
who absolutely love david loved working
for him and i don't think that
there's any real comfort that we could
offer his family today but i hope they
draw some small comfort from just how
much
um you know a husband a father was just
loved right across the political
spectrum in the house of commons and
evidently loved by his constituents as
we've seen in the outpouring of grief
and love for david in the last day or so
the conversation this morning has
centered very much on the security
of members of parliament and uh i would
guess also local councillors who have to
meet people they don't know face to face
and there's some suggestion that
actually over recent times things have
become
more dangerous
uh
certainly rougher
has either of you
have you had to take
extra precautions over your period uh as
members of parliament andrew rossendale
first
um yes i'm afraid
i've been mp 20 years and during that
period
uh i see
a lot of more nasty people around than
ever before and they're willing to say
and do things
in a way that i would never thought
possible in this country and we all have
to be really aware and keep our wits
about us the abuse we get on social
media by emails i mean we get it all the
time but we brush it off because we've
got a job to do and
we tell the police the police have got
other things to do it's not always
followed up
and i think probably this is all going
to change we've got to take this a bit
more seriously in future i've had my
office was arsoned my car was smashed up
someone tried to get into my house and
injure me managed to stop them all these
things have happened over the years but
you take it in your stride because
our priority is to to get on with our
job and we we we do tend to not think
much about our own security i'm afraid
but i'm thinking now maybe we should do
a bit more um
pretty patel's reviewing
how we're going to be how this is going
to be dealt with in future certainly our
constituency surgeries there's going to
be have to be some new arrangements for
those but we can't let evil destroy
democracy and this was pure evil what
happened here we cannot allow that to
undermine the democratic traditions of
this country so whatever happens
where's myself and all members of
parliament we're going to be out there
serving our constituents we're not going
to let this defeat us we'll still be
there and doing the job we're elected to
do
we're streeting andrew rosendale says we
have to do a bit more
what in your view would a bit more in
practical terms constitute
i think it's a good question trevor and
i don't know what the answer is to be
honest um
i think the thing about the
accessibility of politicians in britain
and it's when i've met politicians from
other countries they they remark upon it
it's not just that we do it because we
feel obliged to and we think it's part
of the job we do it because we love
doing it we love spending time in our
communities we love spending time with
our constituents um we you know we're
people people we like spending time with
people that's why we're in politics to
make a difference and to serve people so
so i think
none of us really want to change that we
don't want to take measures that that
undermine that but we're having
difficult conversations with our own
families this is not just about us it's
about the safety of our staff the people
who work for us it's about you know how
our families feel when we go off to work
and the conversation that particularly
you know our colleagues who are parents
have been having with their children
in the last day or so about why our jobs
important and why it's worth the risk
but you know this is the second
second
incident like this in five years and you
know it's we've been stricken with grief
for david grief for joe
and you know and also grief for the job
that we do in a sense because
you know
we love it we love what we do
david was the epitome of loving public
service
um so we know that something's got to
change but it you know i think
it's so raw and we don't want to kind of
rush to kind of
snap judgments but we know something's
got to change
there's a lot of talk about reviews and
consideration and so on but
are we going to be here again in
three years four years five years
uh as frankly we were on to
the joe cox murder where everybody said
we have things have to change
but actually
it's hard to
identify a practical measure that has
been taken
wes
i i really hope not
you know the truth is that we
we are exposed every day to risk but
i want to take it serious but i also
think that there are lots of people who
expose to risk every day who serve the
public
we're not unique in that sense and we're
not a special case
um
and i don't want people watching your
program this morning who would be
outstanding public servants whether as
counsellors or members of parliament or
working in other public-facing roles to
think this is no longer for me i don't
want to do that i i can't tell you
trevor how much i love doing this job um
and i know i speak for andrew on this
because you know
lived in your constituency at one point
parliamentary neighbours even though
andrew drives around my constituency
every election with his loud hailer
trying to get me out you know i can sit
around you a cross-party friend um we
love doing this job absolutely love it
and i wouldn't want anyone to be put off
but part of that has got to be i'm sure
making sure we're safe
andrew rosendale
um
many people would say that
part of what we are seeing now
is an atmosphere that has generated by
a heightened rhetoric
and the way that people talk about talk
about and to each other in politics at
not least members of parliament
themselves to what extent
do you think that this changed
atmosphere actually
uh is the responsibility of
parliamentarians themselves call you
know people who call others enemies of
the people people who call other people
scum for example
so
we're all in politics and we accept that
we are going to be criticized for our
views not everyone agrees with our
opinions and i don't mind a political
debate i don't mind people attacking me
because they disagree with my views on
whatever subject it may be however there
is a level to which that's it is
acceptable
to have that kind of debate if you use
nasty hateful language if you if you use
language which is going to
place you in a position whereby you look
like you
you hate that person because their views
that's not acceptable and there are
some politicians who have said things
they shouldn't have said
um i don't think that's been the cause
of this though it may be part of the
background to i don't know we'll find
out in due course but we we all have a
responsibility to show respect for each
other to show kindness um despite our
political differences and where's the
probably example of that you know we're
neighboring seats we've never had a bad
word to say about each other that quite
the opposite
but we have different views on issues um
we always will because we're different
parties but it doesn't stop us being
friends and colleagues it doesn't stop
us working together on issues and we
agree on far more than the public think
actually uh it's amazing how many mps on
other side of the house that i agree
with on issues and it's not all it's not
all um
bad feeling between us and sometimes the
media can project it like we're all at
each other but we're not
there's a lot of things that we agree on
work together on
but we've got them be careful of our
language and we've all got to make sure
that when we speak in public and when we
tweet things out and when we issue
statements that that we show respect for
other people even if they're
diametrically opposed to our particular
point of view
we're streeting um
i
remember
after
joe cox died
much of the language that we're hearing
this weekend of kindness and
more in common than we that separates us
and so on being used and people
promising
that they would be more respectful and
so on um
i think it took roughly six weeks for
members of parliament to be yelling at
each other across the
aisle again
now
you know you two
are not known particularly for that kind
of thing
what can we actually do
to make sure that all of the good
intentions that are going to be
expressed today and tomorrow and the day
after
last into next year
well it takes it takes work and it takes
um some effort and um you know i think
you're a bit too generous there i can i
think if you ask the speaker or
successive speakers i've got quite a
loud voice in the commons chamber and
the irony is as much as people say they
don't like the the the jeering and the
yelling at prime minister's questions
it's the most watched part of the week
um
i i i think that
the the the the rough and humble of
politics the you know the the argue
bhaji of debate that's part of it i
think there are times when you know
intemperate language can go too far and
i wish that it wouldn't take awful
tragedies like this for us to
remind ourselves and particularly to
remind the public that we do actually
quite like each other actually across
the political spectrum there are lots of
cross-party friendships and as i say
whenever i do a school visit in my
constituency when i look across the
commons chamber to conservative mps i
don't see a bunch of people who are evil
i see people who like me are motivated
by a commitment to public service and
wanting to make our country a better
place we just differ on how to do that
and that's what politics is all about
and and i think we can make that point
uh more often without losing robust
debate i think robust debate is a
healthy part of democracy um but i think
i think perhaps we might impugn each
other's motives a little less um
and also i mean i think we've also got
to
it's always a time to talk about
civility and politics i think we've also
got to reflect on the specific
circumstances of as to how two members
of parliament um have lost their lives
in this way and i think that's about
more than civility it's about extremism
we've got to tackle that too
right we're streeting andrew rosendale
thank you very much indeed for joining
us